ladies do yourself a favor find yourself
we know someone who took that advice
crechelle
stouse oh my gosh i'm so excited
yep the recent dancing with the stars
contestant is dating one of the show's
pro dancers
keo matsepe it's a very very unique and
special
connection check out this pda moment
they both shared to social media
keo's arm wrapped around christelle's
waist seemingly
sweetly kissing the side of her face
here's another adorable snap
they also hit the gym together
and prepare to swoon watching this
flirty moment
bye
[Laughter]
a source tells et that the pair has been
dating for a couple of weeks
and clearly haven't been shy about
showing off their pda
in front of other dancing with the stars
cast members
just check out the comments section the
pair got all sorts of love from fellow
pros
daniela cheryl allen pasha
sasha and even christelle's former
partner gleb
krishel's fellow contestants weighed in
too jeannie mai
caitlyn bristow neve shulman and monica
aldama
all left supportive messages our source
adds quote
things have been heating up and they're
very into each other
but it's not super serious but i'm
so happy it's been a journey to finding
romance again for the 39 year old
selling sunset star
she married this is us actor justin
hartley in 2017
but in november 2019 he filed for
divorce
krishel opened up about the blindsiding
moment on her reality series
i found out because he text me
that we were filed he text you
45 minutes later the world knew now
krishell is seemingly living her best
life not only is she crushing it as a
real estate agent
she also made it to midway in the
competition on dancing with the stars
and was even nominated for a 2020
daytime emmy award
for her guest starring role on days of
our lives
and when et spoke with christelle in
september she hinted that she was
warming up to the idea of starting to
date again
by the way i feel like with the summer
you've had
and now going on dancing with the stars
people got to be sliding into your dms
i have to say i have had
a few yes it's been yeah i don't know
how to answer that i feel so weird but
yes that has been
a nice surprise anybody we might know
there's a few but i'm not going to tell
you who
okay but but right now you're single and
ready to keep mingling
completely single and because of covet i
haven't done much mingling i'm excited
to mingle
the actress also shared her refreshing
outlook on life
because you don't know how short life is
you don't know how what you're
you know how long you're gonna be here
to how
what you're you know you're not promised
anything and so
if any if this year has taught me
anything it's just you know
even if it scares you just say yes dress
up
show up get out there
you